just this week North Carolina joined
other states in passing a 12-week
abortion ban and since this Summer's U.S
Supreme Court ruling over turning Roe v
Wade many doctors have seen an increase
in patients seeking a vasectomy and you
spoke to a specialist about the trends
he's seen at his practice
32-year-old Kevin urb and his wife Renee
have two fur babies plenty of parenting
for them my wife and I just decided that
we didn't want to have kids they weighed
their options she could go on birth
control or he could get a vasectomy a
lot easier to do one thing that was
pretty quick and relatively inexpensive
and not have to worry about it ever
again he got
done at vasectomy Pro with Dr T J Morris
Dr Morris has an office in Henderson and
several in Utah Morris says the Supreme
Court's decision increased awareness and
vasectomy requests the first few months
after it he and his staff were working
overtime to accommodate patients he is
still very busy scheduling procedures
every 15 minutes completing about 20 to
30 vasectomies a day this is an office
procedure it literally takes a couple
minutes there's no needles there's no
scalpel while the average age of clients
is men in their 30s or 40s who are done
having more children Dr Morris is seeing
a new trend among younger patients
uptick in the younger men you know under
30 no children looking for permanent
birth control now that that they feel
like that the abortion aspect is is not
kind of like a safety net for them
that's kind of you know
um sparked the conversation for that
Kevin says it was a simple decision and
procedure offering peace of mind for
both he and his wife there was like
literally no pain whatsoever I was in
with Dr Morris for maybe 10 minutes and
then the next day everything was
completely back to normal
and the duck says men can schedule their
consult the procedure for the same day
he also says you should consider this a
permanent procedure while they do
perform reversals he does warn his
patients that reversals don't always
work